dans les rues de paris c'est un rythme
maintenant établie 30 kilomètres à
l'heure voilà la nouvelle ligne est
imposé sur presque tous les axes
routiers paris est une ville extrêmement
petit très très dense avec beaucoup de
conflits d'usagé entre eux par exemple
les automobilistes les deux roues
motorisés les vélos et puis les piétons
selon lui la réduction de vitesse a fait
ses preuves dans d'autres villes
européennes à bruxelles c'est moins 25 %
d'accidents graves depuis que la vitesse
maximale est passé de 50 km/heure à 30
km heure là où cette mesure a été mise
en place et bien on envoie des effets
sur la sécurité des individus la mesure
vise aussi à s'attaquer à la pollution
sonore et pour ce qui est de la lutte
contre les changements climatiques
les effets directs sont beaucoup moins
claires une étude récente d'une agence
publique avance même que la voiture
serait moins polluante à des vitesses
supérieures à 30 kilomètres à l'heure
mais à terme cette mesure pourrait
contribuer à réduire le nombre de
véhicules sur les routes à 30 km heure
on va aussi revoir l'organisation de la
voirie qu'elle soit mieux partagé entre
les automobilistes et cyclistes et
piétons et donc ces quelques centimètres
qu'on enlèvera aux voitures on pourra
les réaffectés à d'autres usages mais
les effets sur la qualité des routes
pour aller voir qu'avec le recul et avec
le temps cette mesure s'inscrit dans une
vision plus large que défend
l'administration parisienne dès l'année
prochaine la ville pourrait grandement
limiter la circulation automobile dans
les arrondissements centraux de paris
seuls certains véhicules seraient
autorisés à y accéder
le but est d'empêcher les automobilistes
de transiter par ces quartiers
d'ailleurs pour coeur de paris un projet
pilote existe déjà sur l'iconique rue de
rivoli ceux qui peuvent y circuler les
transports en commun les taxis et les
véhicules de livraison et les voitures
des commerçants et résidents ce sont des
très grands axes des axes majeurs qui
bloquent complètement la circulation qui
crée une thrombose ça des répercussions
sur l'activité économique ce a des
répercussions sur l'activité commerçante
les commerces de niche qui ont une
clientèle on va dire varié de
banlieusards qui viennent de loin pour
un commerce spécifique mais il n'aime
plus selon ce conseiller d'opposition
d'autres méthodes comme le péage serait
plus efficace pour contrôler la
circulation
il déplore la proche de l'administration
et à la méthode de l'emmerdement c'est à
dire on crée du bouchon ont créé des
nounous circulation qui sont
infranchissables mais pour les
dirigeants de la ville pas question de
changer de direction pour transformer la
ville pour l'adapter aux dérèglements
climatiques eh bien oui nous avons
besoin aujourd'hui et bien de diminuer
la place de la voiture cette stratégie
passe entre autres par la limite à 30 km
à l'heure une mesure qui selon un récent
sondage obtient l'appui d'une majorité
de résidants de la ville de toute façon
la nouvelle règle ne changera
pratiquement rien au quotidien de
nombreux automobilistes parisiens roux
le pos plu 30 km c'est tout le temps
boucher donc
on n'est jamais à 30 on est toujours à
12 15 km heure il sait rafale movie
auclair radio canada